Reggie Miller Hall of Famer Turner
Sports NBA analyst and part of the
all-star festivities he's got the
Celtics bucks this Thursday night 8:00
Eastern on TNT and reg joins us now
tired a little bit weekend and as you
know because you've hit me during a lot
of my telecast and I am usually quick to
respond to you back usually something I
said or yeah you're walking and you want
to you know give me some advice or
whatever but there were so many moving
parts this week in which there normally
are during the all-star game in the
weekend and the events and the game so I
apologize I didn't hit you back but
there was a lot going on and to LeBron
James point I like the words I like the
tone that he's saying but I will say
this it's not the second half of the
season which doesn't work in their favor
it's a sprint now I mean there's only 24
25 games left for most of these teams so
they've got to hit the ground running
and the good thing about what Luke
Walton has I believe long the ball would
be back Josh Hart will be back you know
they've had a rash of injuries that led
up to all this LeBron James obviously
will be back so they've got to get on a
run but guess what
San Antonio Sacramento they're not going
to make life easy for them they're not
going to make life easy for them to get
that number
eighth spot in five years from now what
will you remember about this past
weekend absolutely nothing no I will
tell you what I really River in five
years is the love that was shown to Dirk
Nowitzki and Dwyane Wade and the
Brotherhood and how much respect those
two guys had obviously they were late
additions added by the Commissioner Adam
Silver to the roster and it was cool
juicy all weekend love all weekend long
the love that those two guys received
because they've been great ambassadors
to the game of basketball they are both
champions but it's the ways
they carried themselves the way they
conducted themselves around the rest of
the players and it was cool to see some
of the younger all-stars you know kind
of become childlike around them and and
step back in the moment and say you know
what someday this could be me if I can
continue to work hard and be a great
ambassador for basketball this could be
me so it was kind of cool to see that
but is the Commissioner going to do this
every year like why why this year well
another thing I was kind of surprised
Vince Carter didn't get asked I know he
hasn't come out and said he's going to
retire but I would have loved I would
love hopefully this happens for Vince
Carter as well I think he's been a great
ambassador for the game of basketball
not only here but remember I think a lot
of Canadians grew up watching Vince
Carter when he played for the Toronto
Raptors and that's when he was probably
at his height so I hope they do this for
Vince as well I'm gonna remember Steph
Curry's bounce pass to the Greek freak
as we look back on this certainly that
was the highlight that was the play
everyone is talking about because if you
look we we might have rolled that replay
20 times and Yanis head and his arms
it's almost like he was getting ready to
touch the top of the backboard and when
when Steph as soon as you went to the
ground with the pass I was like there's
no way this is going over the backboard
and then I was like wait a minute
who's on the other side and there was
the Greek freak and he kept going and
going and going up it was it was
spectacular play which turns to my why
doesn't Yanis get in the slam dunk
competition all right I just saw where
Donovan Mitchell tweeted to the Greek
freak if you're in I'm in I can they
offer a big prize money how much do you
win do you win anything other than a
trophy if you win a slam dunk on top
yeah money that okay yeah there is a
monetary advantage to winning but if
Greek was in and if spotted Mitchell
came back and you know you're gonna have
Diane Williamson next year too
yeah now you need one more throwing a
bin Simmons maybe you know we need if
you want the dunk contest to come back
you need names as much as I love Hama
dude Diallo
he won if you walked into your studio
right now no one would know who he is
right yeah no one really knows who Jason
Collins is Dennis Jr who was traded to
the Knicks that's great and all but they
don't know who these guys are what you
set $100,000 to your chair or $100,000
or $500,000 like make it a must-see TV
event
[Music]
yeah but reg curry had nothing to gain
by being in a three-point shooting stop
it right and that's to me the highlight
for me Saturday night with the
three-point competition yeah when you
get the role that he had on in the
finals when he made like 10 or 11 in a
row and you got 224 and you still lose
24 any other competition hands down
you're hoisting the trophy Joe Harris
had back-to-back unbelievable rounds of
25 in 26 to put the defending champ down
there was some there was some unreal
shooting in the three-point competition
unreal it was so exciting I'm talking to
Reggie Miller the Hall of Famer Turner
Sports NBA analyst there were a hundred
and seventy sixty seven three-pointers
attempted and the only player who didn't
attempt a three-point shot was Ben
Simmons
[Music]
the game was three-pointers I was hoping
that was gonna be his game plan that he
was into nothing but shoot
three-pointers I mean I would have been
brilliant for a guy that has not who was
a number one pick who is a guard that
has not made a three-point basket in his
young career and I think he I believe
he's only attempted like 12 or 13 11
4:11 oh my god if I said straight up
Tatum for Simmons I would not do it
because of the intangibles that Simmons
says see okay so you like Shannon's more
than Tim I do I do like them as more
than Tatum because he can add that shot
I don't want him to he doesn't need to
be a 3-point shot but he needs a 16 to
19 foot respectable keep you honest
theater Dan Patrick jump shot but rich
boy but he if you get to be 19 or 20 and
you don't have a jumper than like it's
okay because with his gait his stride
his length his power one if he's facing
you up and he could knock that down
consistently and you got to crowd him
one dribble and I'm at the rim one
dribble help comes I'm throwing an alley
to impede one dribble I'm finding JD now
I'm flying
finding Harris but he's got to get a
jump shot because right now it's fine
you know you know how playoff basketball
is win teams there's no more travel yeah
there's no more back-to-back I break out
the CD the VCR what are the DVR and I
think everything away from you all your
top plays and that's exactly what boss
that's why Boston is brilliant against
them because they take away all his
strengths which is in the pain there
were a couple things said and they were
from two guys who don't even play
anymore Michael Jordan was talking about
he was asked about the greatness of
Harden in Westbrook
and then he said yeah but you know
what's tougher is winning six NBA titles
which I don't know if Mike needed that
but Mike of course being Mike you know
it's like scoreboard for him and then
Scottie Pippen's saying that LeBron is
nowhere near Michael Jordan or Kobe
because he lacks the clutch gene I'm a
little confused by what Scottie said
because there's me flip-flopping years
yes a few years ago he said he would
take LaRon over Michael and we
was an opera that was your teammate
Michael George got you six rings what
are you talking about and now maybe he
had a come-to-jesus moment with MJ and
now he is flip-flop like they're totally
different players
Kobe MJ and LeBron Michael and Kobe they
would tear your heart out they wanted to
destroy you they wanted to embarrass you
in front of your family LeBron he wants
to set the table that's not saying he
doesn't have a killer angsting doesn't
mean that he's not clutched we've seen
him make big baskets and big plays we
also seen him fail I filled in big
moments Kobe has failed in big moments
MJ has failed a big moment so it happens
but for him to say they he's not a
clutch player I don't agree with that I
think when you get three championships
you find a way to be clutch you find a
way to make plays
but for MJ and his comments come would
you expect anything less it's like his
Hall of Fame speech where he's just
tearing people down
I give us a roast when he went into the
Hall of Fame and people need to look at
the whole clip because he did give kudos
to James Harden and he did give kudos to
Russell Westbrook on their achievements
and what they're accomplished
accomplishing 11 straight and Counting
triple doubles for Westbrook who wrote
who broke Wilt Chamberlain's record and
the 30 point streak that hardens on so
he did give them kudos yeah but it was a
backward compliment because it all came
back to your oh by the way if you're
asking me was harder well drinks kiss
all six of them please if you may media
so yeah it was a backward complan but
but I don't expect any less from the go
most famous person you ran into over the
weekend non-athlete it's always a
pleasure to see Oscar winner Jamie Foxx
that's cool
it's funny you know Robert Kraft the
owner of the Patriots is wearing all his
rings and his blinged out puma shoes or
Nike shoes or whatever he was wearing
it's just cool to be in that atmosphere
because everyone comes out you know this
is what separates the NBA all-star game
from major league and the Pro Bowl the
proximity to the fans have to the
players
I mean players are bringing out
celebrities for the slam dunk for the
props for the alley-oops you don't get
that in baseball you can't bring out a
celebrity try to pitch you know to Manny
Machado or you know celebrities not
gonna put on pads and a helmet and you
know take a hit from von Miller the
celebs get into this because they are so
close to the action and it's great
instagramming because everyone has their
camera phones out everyone's mingling
this is what separates the NBA all-star
game from any sports league best
non-athlete playing basketball player if
that makes sense
[Music]
all two chambers
oh yeah okay can Meek Mill play I
haven't seen him play personally but 2
Chainz is like he's like 6 4 and with a
jump shot you got game yeah you got game
I actually this is what I would love to
see a game of horse between Fedor
Patrick and 2 Chainz in fact I'm gonna
make that happen
money for charity I'm gonna put up I'm
three chains I would want to do that oh
would you make it to reach a yeah I make
it rain chains can play all right what
about the game do I need to worry about
the game Tuesday no no in there a rapper
called the game oh the game no just
don't talk any noise to the game okay
right there no oh
talking me know because I know you like
to talk I will say that thought I will
not say would you rather have your
career or Jamie Foxx's career actor
versus athlete yeah there's more
longevity and acting Jamie Foxx will be
acting until he's 70 you see a whole
Famer though he's got an Oscar is that
the Hall of Fame mm-hmm that's the Hall
of Fame it's closed you have enough
that's the Hall of Fame all right all
right so you take Jamie ponch's career
and I can work until I'm 70 yeah because
I can't play you you know I played till
I was 39
yeah be good broadcast to year 70 that
was fun I just wanted to make sure I was
texting the right number since I didn't
hear back from you on Saturday or Sunday
but I have I ever not hit you back in
the middle of a telecast either laughing
at what you did to me or her framing you
were right the Glen Rice comment was
funny Glen Rice was when I played
against him because he was a heck of a
scorer shooter and ball you just said
they look like he ate her shooters that
what you said okay does Glen no you said
it he probably does a good weekend it
was fun all right get some rest and I'll
talk to you later
you got it hi that's Reggie Aloysius
Miller junior the third for more Dan
Patrick show to the audio
2:39 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]